L'investissement dans notre défense crée de l'emploi
et donc ce faisant
nous permet de baisser les dépenses sociales
qui accompagnent
et permet de créer de la richesse pour tout le pays.
La guerre c'est bon pour le l'emploi.
Je ne dirai pas les choses comme ça, je préfère la paix.
Samedi 13/04 au soir,
l'Iran et certains de ces alliés ont lancé 1
bombardement d'envergure sur le sol israélien.
1 centaine de drones
et des centaines de missiles
ont été tirés depuis l'Iran,
l'Irak, le Yemen et le Liban.
Cette hypostyranienne a été conçu
pour occasionner le moins de dégâts possible
en prévenant à l'avance l'ensemble des pays de la
région dont Israël
ainsi que les États-Unis. Mais depuis ce weekend,
la communauté
internationale
retient son souffle car cette riposte d'envergure
s'inscrit dans l'accélération d'une crise
régional aux conséquences planétaires.
Si cette repose tyrannienne est
impressionnante par son envergure,
elle n'était pas inattendue puisqu'elle répondait
à 1 attaque de l'état israélien
le 1ère avril dernier,
des F 16 Israéliens
bombardait le consulat iranien à Damas,
faisant 12 morts
dont 1 des généraux Iraniens les plus gradés.
Alors que les alliés d'Israël, dont la France,
ont bloqué 1 résolution des
Nations Unies pour condamner l'attaque israélienne.
Le régime dictatorial iranien
cherche à garantir ses propres
intérêts aux prochoriens
et maintenir 1 rapport de force stratégique
vis-à-vis d'Israël.
Accroché à 1 régime fascisant et ultra religieux.
Nathan Yahoo, lui,
n'a qu'une stratégie pour rester le plus longtemps
possible au pouvoir,
la guerre. 1 Guerre
qui embrasserait l'ensemble du Moyen-Orient
de manière à obliger les États-Unis à intervenir
directement dans le conflit,
changer
radicalement les rapports de force dans la région
mais aussi sur la scène politique israélienne.
Les États-Unis s'y refusent pour l'instant
car pris entre 2 conflits majeurs,
l'Ukraine d'une part et la Palestine de l'autre.
Ils sont conscients qu'un
engagement militaire aurait des conséquences
irréversibles sur la situation
internationale. Pourtant,
le gouvernement se
tarque d'avoir aidé Israël
à intercepter les missiles et drônes iraniennes,
ce que, au passage,
ils ne font pas en Ukraine,
malgré les tirs russes quasi quotidiens
pour le soutien aux ukrainiens.
Nos gouvernements sont croyants
mais pas pratiquants,
ce qui n'empêche pas nos états de se militariser
et de se préparer au retour des
conflits de haute intensité
entre grande puissance.
On est passé de 9,5 à 15 milliards d'euros de commande
et là nous sommes maintenant à 20,
c'est-à-dire que tu es lui.
On a doublé les commandes militaires,
donc on a
donné de la visibilité à l'industrie de défense
et derrière on a créé de l'emploi.
Jusqu'à quand le
gouvernement vont-ils laisser l'état israélien
mener 1 guerre génocidaire à Gaza et mettre le feu au
Moyen-Orient ? La seule sortie de crise possible,
c'est d'imposer 1 CC, le feu à Gaza,
l'embarco sur les armes et des sanctions
contre le régime israélien.
Bon courage, bon retour à tous et toutes hein !